this morning president trump plans to
speak to thousands of his supporters
who are in washington to protest the
election results
there are increasing warnings about some
of those supporters
potentially spreading violence in the
capitol jeff pigues is at the site of
this morning's rally just
outside the white house jeff what is
happening right now
anthony a lot of tension in the air this
morning
as we build up to this event but what
you can see behind me
is all these people tens
of thousands potentially already here
this early in the morning and they are
walking
this way because they are trying to get
into the ellipse we're on constitution
avenue here in washington dc
usually there is traffic auto traffic
here but this morning you see
there is people traffic here so the
president's supporters they are out in
force i talked to one man who came this
morning and he said it's about the
future they also said by the way
if they thought last night's georgia
vote they thought it was rigged
so that is the atmosphere here but in
the air this tension because also
police law enforcement the national
guard concerned
that there could be violence today of
course everybody is hoping that there
won't be
tony back to you all right jeff began
for us in washington d.c
jeff stay safe for us